[музика]
це Конотоп невелике містечко на Сумщині
тут трамваї ходять кулями що їх звичайні
конотопці проклали власноруч центр
прикрашає пам'ятник коню один з
небагатьох в Україні і можливо чаклують
справжні Конотопські відьми
[музика]
тоді росіяни так і не зайшли в місто
Воно місяць було в оточенні а 364 роки
тому російська армія тут зазнала
нищівної поразки у конотопській битві
Нині ж у містечку триває битва духовна з
російськими радянськими назвами вулиць
Це просто мега архіва це не те що це
супер на часі Я считаю що ще це лишнє
пробували боротися Ми продовжуємо
боротися
щоб не перейменували
у Конотопі 427 вулиць провулків і площ у
2015 році перейменували понад 70 з них з
2022 року змінилися ще 44 назви на черзі
більше сотні тобто незабаром оновиться
Кожен другий топонім у місті на думку
міського голови це вклад у майбутню
перемогу над Росією супер на часі бо на
часі це було ще 91-му році треба було
зробити аби ми тоді очистилися
енергетично очистилася очистилися
ментально духовно очистили ці всі
тапеніми прибрали ось ми тоді змогли
набагато легше швидше прибрати з
свідомості багатьох оцей комплекс
меншовартості це хохлізм оцей віднедавна
коно
топом автобуси подарунок від чеського
міста острава а на честь директора
комунального підприємства яке передало
автобуси Даніеля Моріса назвали ось цю
вулицю Новий транспорт сюди поки не
їздить А місцеві жителі через понад
півроку після перейменування ще
користуються старою назвою 6 вересня за
радянських часів ця назва з'явилася з
нагоди звільнення міста від фашистів
раніше це був і день міста це
вилучається вулиці купили автобусами
щоб не перейменували
ми перейменували Я вважаю що нормально
назва була міста вулиці Вишнева тут
вишень росте хай би Вишнева була Щоб
ніколи ніхто не міняв її А ця вулиця
колишня Тургенєва віднедавна носить ім'я
Валерія залужного її жителі до нової
назви ставляться здебільшого позитивно
нормально
набагато краще жить там між придавно всі
ухожу на краще жити коли все доглянуте
все добре на будь-якій вулиці названий
грає жодної ролі як на мене
тут стільки з посів зламали коли
змінювали в 2014 році Що тепер я все
спокійно сприймаю за лужного так
залужного
так залужного у Києві ж свого часу
відмовилися від ідеї назвати вулицю
іменем головнокомандувача ЗСУ адже
законом встановлено що вулицям
присвоюється імена фізичних осіб лише
посмертно у міського голови Конотопа
батьки якого нині живуть на вулиці
залужного є свої аргументи деяких
питаннях
[музика]
ментального характеру деяких питаннях
якраз стратегічного патріотичного
характеру я вважаю що десь якщо ми
Приймемо рішення які не заборонено по
суті то нічого тут поганого немає для
Валерія залужного ми всі ми вдячні да ну
не можемо вийти зараз такі на простити
Дякую за лужний Да і ми від імені всієї
громади підтримати його
показати що Ми віримо в його талант
віримо його справедливість і силу Ми
назвали вулицю про його честь Тобто це
від усієї нашої 100-тисячної громади це
йому такі аналітичний посил найбільш
суперечок у Конотопі викликало
перейменування вулиці красногірської на
варшавську дехто у назві красногірська
бачить радянський слід дехто ні так
слово само Красне що це то село якесь
Красне то
вулиця Красна та ще щось
не интересно так хай лучше який стають
бо будуть назви чи нові якісь
красногірська що це красна гора чи що
вона вліяє Я не знаю
тепер Варшавська
нам до Варшави ще далеко
там проспект Леніна був Ну там ладно это
да А так що можна було і не
перейменувати у нас более глобальні
проблеми в городе
чем улицы співробітник місцевого
краєзнавчого музею Олександр акуліч теж
не згоден з перейменуванням Він вивчає
історію Конотопа і проводить історичні
екскурсії містом красногірська є
історична назва вона таки з'явилася під
такою назвою ще її перша згадка 1725 рік
і відштовхуються вони як красные горки
це як ото Володимир красне сонечко все
була одним із тих що тригерів після
котрого
прискіпливо ставляться до деяких
перейменувань порути перейменування
виступив депутат міськради Андрій
Франчук в окрузі якого розташована
колишня красногірська і активісти з
громадської організації 35 квартал їх
обурило і те що інші вулиці всупереч
закону назвали іменами живих людей
Моріса і залужного а також відсутність
громадських обговорень
перейменовуємо вулиці в честь людей з
іншої держави яка
ключова передала нам просто
автобуси А у нас кожен день гинуть герої
начебто спустилися децентралізацію і
логіка повинна полягати в тому що в
громаді сила виходять Так що на місцях в
якісь стирки з'являються і можуть без
думки обговорення людей приймати такі
рішення активі
сти знувань
зібрав міський голова вважає супротив
перейменуванню політичним піаром
опонентів в самому тексті петиції
написано відмінити повністю рішення
тобто не в частині там однієї чи двох
вулиць з якими він там на яких він там
політичний піар собі робить а відмінити
повністю все рішення а це рішення
містилось зокрема перейменування однієї
з вулиць міста одні з центральних вулиць
міста на
вулиці яка носить тепер ім'я Романа
Шухевича
уявляєте Тобто це животное яке виконує
очевидно якісь
чиї замовлення щодо думки громадськості
то нові назви для вулиць обговорювала
спеціальна комісія з дер русифікації
пояснює міський голова містян нам
пропонували долучитися до дискусії на
сторінці міськради у Фейсбуці конотопці
з якими поспілкувалася ДВ не знали Ані
про таке обговорення Ані про фа
перейменування вулиць вже перейменували
[музика]
як казати
її слухати в інституті нацпам'яті
наголошують про це з перейменування має
бути зрозумілим громаді в кожного
випадку потрібно досліджувати вивчати
піднімати архіви тому тут в цій роботі
надзвичайно важлива участь і дослідників
істориків краєзнавців для того щоб
справді цей процес був виважений
обґрунтований і
був зрозумілим для всіх новий закон про
засудження російської імперської
політики в Україні та деколонізацію то
набув чинності наприкінці липня цьогоріч
за ним впродовж півроку з публічного
простору мають зникнути російський
радянські топоніми є винятки для
постатей які зробили значний внесок у
розвиток певного регіону чи України
загалом комісія інституту нацпам'яті
розроблятиме рекомендації для органів
місцевого самоврядування що підпадає під
перейменування А що ні Як краще обрати
нову назву поки така комісія у процесі
створення назва вулиці це не лише як
вияв пошани до творчості того чи іншого
письменника насправді радянський час це
був фактично маркером вищості російської
культури і тому усунення отаких Марків є
надзвичайно ну Важливим сьогодні це
навіть відкриває шлях для того щоб ми
краще більше дізнавалися дізнавало
власну історію і бачили
увічнювали пам'ять про тих хто
насправді пов'язаний з тим чи іншим
сію чи іншою громадою з тим чи іншим
містом чи селом з конотопським
краєзнавцем Олександром макулічем ми
говоримо На пере
хресть Червоної Калини і Варшавської
раніше красногірської Олександр каже
війна значно підігріла цікавість
місцевих до його історичних екскурсій і
минулого рідного міста так як я до 24
лютого майже не проживав у місті
працював у Києві живкою ось постійно в
Києві то мені не давала ентузіазму
приїздити ще на вихідний і коли пише що
дає екскурсія тут приходить дві людини і
ти такий думаєш і навіщо я сюди їхав і
кому це цікаво а от
після повномасштабного вторгнення у
людей
з'явились цікавинка де вони живуть у
Конотопі за 80 кілометрів від
російського кордону поки побоюються
вішати нові таблички для перейменованих
вулиць заради конспірації
але не бояться класти нові дороги Хоча
не всюди показує нам Павло місцевий
активіст це Європейська площа була
перейменована в рамках декомунізації
2015 році раніше називалася площею
Новікова
і Ну якось за 8 чи навіть 9 років так ну
Особливо тут нічого не змінилося
ну принаймні не в європейську сторону
Так точно
у публічний Павло каже що мріє пов’язати
своє життя з Конотопом хлопець хоче аби
місто змінювалося не лише номінально ми
зверталися до влади ми казали що Ну
давайте може будемо змінювати не так
багато вулиць але за той будемо
змінювати щось на них фундаментально ну
наприклад якщо ми
змінили назву вулиці ми там створюємо
ОСББ проводимо якусь модернізацію
банально робимо ремонтно дитячих
майданчиках цієї вулиці це не дуже
дорого і це дійсно потрібно
[музика]